you guys about the weight and enter and
redemption and we're in regards to
getting it out there getting it seen it
is something that you went to the film
festival with how did you go about
getting the movie scene uh the weight or
botham I want to film a couple film
festivals I think of the Sundance and
maybe Slamdance and you know there is
the festival circuit and it's and it's
you know I could dive into that but I
you know my funds are limited so you
know you've got choices when you don't
have a lot of funds it's because just to
get into the the gamut of film festivals
you have to make an investment into that
and I had to choose either invest in you
know pushing the weight into festivals
and seeing that with that could get for
me and the weights of dark films so I
already knew it was going to be you know
it's a niche film it could only fit in
certain markets and things like that so
I didn't think it was worth it to invest
that deep into the film to get it seen
so I put it online and you know just let
it run its course and moved on and I put
the rest of that money I had in to
redemption and then it was in and it's
funny it's kind of the same thing we're
redemption my money is limited so it's
like okay should I go make the next
project or should I try to push this one
for the next year or so so put it on the
internet and see what happens with it
and I save my money for the amber
trailer now this projects different this
project I'm not moving forward with
anything else until this projects easy
you know it comes to fruition so this is
a different story so amber I'm going to
run my course with Amber and I'm going
to you know put my you know investments
into this and push it and try to this
one I'm going to go hold full tilt to
get out there for the public because I
you know out of all the projects this
one is a worthy cause it's a worthy
project and I think this is one it is a
great first project for me to bring to
the public and what lessons did you gain
with the two short films going right
online by patching the film festivals
what what kind
we're reaction response did you get it
was positive I definitely got positive
reactions from the film but I think I
lacked the connections that you would
get if i went and invested into the
festival's that's the one thing I think
that I lack you know when I when it
comes time to make a product and I
finish min and I'm like hey I'm done am
I gonna show it to come I guess I
included in any festivals and you know
so it's like who's gonna watch this so I
think the first two projects were more
for me to see what I needed to see as a
director to gain the confidence enough
to start actually you know shooting my
films as features because I've written a
number of screenplays I could have
picked any one of those to do the first
projects but as a first one to tackle
your feature out they would have been
ludicrous so I started with the shorts
and I write a short tailor it to
something that I could handle and that
was the weight in one room isolated I
could handle that and redemption was
again one room but more complicated
because I was in it was physical you
know it was a you know it was a more
action-oriented short so that that was a
different than the amber was my test for
myself the trailer to see if I could
handle multiple locations you know with
different lighting setups you know in a
fast-paced guerrilla style can I pull it
off you know and I had I think ten
different locations and you know pulled
it off in two days and and when I see
that and I look at the footage and i
said i look at the screenplay and i say
did I represent myself well when I look
at the script and and what I see on the
image and I like it and I wouldn't move
forward if I didn't think I could do it
so you know I'd make another short you
know so I'd say I learned a lot about
the shorts putting them out there but uh
and I definitely got some positive
feedback but you know for me it's amber
I think this is where I'm really going
to learn what it's like to put a project
out to the public you know I think this
is where i'll be able to answer that
question because the other shows i'll
put online and kind of promoted a little
bit facebook and things like that but
not a real push for festivals and things
but uh amber is gonna be my first one
I'm gonna go after the film market
someone each other you know vote of cans
and
I'm going to take it to all the markets
that I can and see you know what the
public thinks about this because I you
know I think it's a worthy endeavor so
you know hopefully people think it is as
well
you